[Music]
what would I do without you you'll
always have me Queen I do know we cannot
wait to hear the lullaby you sing to
Anna and Elsa when they were little
girls they didn't know it at the time
but you were giving Elsa clues about the
source of her powers and you put those
secrets in a lullaby so they would never
forget what they are
while Elsa and Donna will miss you
always your song will live on in their
hearts forever there are some major
clues in the new epic frozen to song
into the unknown this song is so much
more than a comforting lullaby
it's loaded with hidden meanings and
messages here is the new frozen 2 song
explained Elsa's got another epic song
to sing in frozen 2 and we can't wait to
hear it everyone loved to let it go they
saw it as the ultimate female
empowerment song so of course fans are
expecting a lot from Elsa's newest two
ballad but will it be the next let it go
watch until the end to find out when
bustled interviewed idea Menzel about
her new valid in frozen 2 she shared the
song really inspired her she said that
all the music in the film really moved
her she added that when she was
interpreting the songs they moved her
even more but what is so inspiring and
moving about this new song thanks to
youtuber frozen boy we were able to hear
an insert of the song into the unknown
snippets of the song play from the new
Elsa doll the lyrics from these snippets
say don't you know there's a part of me
that longs to go when you push the
button again Elsa sings the chorus into
the unknown
this song pretends an adventure on the
horizon for Elsa Anna Kristoff and Olaf
the past is not what it seems
we know she will be travelling across
the sea to a faraway land
will this be the place where she
discovers the source of her powers no
Disney showed a sneak peek at the d23
Expo that revealed the new song
according to Screen Rant
the first clip showed a flashback to
Anna and Elsa's childhood memory of
their mother Queen I do know played by
Evan Rachel Wood sings him a lullaby
while they snuggle in her lap then they
jumped to the present where Anna Elsa
Kristoff and Olaf are playing charades
but Elsa's distracted by something weird
to you she ends the game and says it's
time for bed Kristoff tries to propose
to a very distracted Anna
however Anna is too concerned about Elsa
to notice Christoph's attempt side note
we are freaking out about the idea of
Anna and Kristoff sweating okay back to
the sneak peek screen rants reported
that Anna tried to comfort her troubled
sister by singing her the lullaby that
their mothers sing to them when they
were young the audience slowly realized
the lyrics of this lullaby uncover a
mystery and will lead to Elsa and Anna
on a great adventure into the unknown
where the lyrics are where the north
wind meets the sea there's a river full
of memory sleep my darling safe and
sound for in this river all is found at
first it sounds like a normal lullaby
sung to little children to sleep but
upon interpretation the true meaning is
uncovered this song is loaded with clues
pointing Elsa to the place where she can
learn about the origin of her powers the
first line where the north wind meets
the sea lines up with the first frozen
to trailer where Elsa is trying to
freeze and run on top of the waves of
the ferocious ocean the next line of the
song there's a river full of memory is
possibly connected to the river we see
Anna and Olaf canoeing through if you
combine those song lyrics with the
trolls message to Elsa to go north
across the enchanted lands you've got a
recipe for an epic adventure in the
sneak peak honest sings Elsa the lullaby
which soothes Elsa to sleep for a little
while but she wakes up to the sound of a
voice in her head she starts singing
along to the song which is into the
unknown it's a big ethic ballad
according to the people who heard the
song at the
23 Expo it's on track to become the next
let it go Elsa wanders through the
castle to try and find where the voice
is coming from she follows the voice out
the window and down a steep cliff using
her ice powers to make a path we know
from the first frozen movie that anytime
Elsa ventures out on the ice alone a
breathtaking musical number is
definitely going to happen however the
song doesn't only belong to Elsa Anna
was there too when their mothers sing
this lullaby that makes us wonder is
into the unknown will be a sister duet
that would be amazing
you know I'm coming in a recent
interview Kristen Bell talked about a
song in the upcoming frozen movie while
she didn't say the title of the song
we're pretty sure she means into the
unknown she said while all of the songs
are very good there is one song in
particular that has been stuck in her
head Kristen really gave it away when
she shared that she had been singing
this song to her daughters ever since
she heard it that reminds us of Queen I
dunno singing a lullaby to young Anna
and Elsa Kristen believes this new song
will be stuck in everyone's heads the
same way let it go was what do you guys
think will into the unknown be the new
let it go sound off in the comments
thanks for watching the things be sure
to subscribe and click the thumbs up
button to never miss another video we'll
see you next time
[Music]